we're back with new neckline probably
the based on a true story
here everyone [ __ ] a lover here I come
back to tell you all that I see how you
make fun of me and I want you all to
know that just because I don't do good
quickscopes and just because my montage
doesn't have any views that doesn't mean
I don't have feelings and yes I may
never become faze clan member and [ __ ]
all average doesn't have to read us
mas'r and how a refreshed my own videos
for more views but that doesn't mean I
don't cry and pour tea pie of you I am
of the most disappoints I unsub your
Channel five times now but I know
dislike
I'm not a hater like you are all to me I
thought you were a cold bro you know but
you're obviously just a homo sapiens but
I'm a giraffe and life isn't easy out
here in Africa
dodging quickscopes left and right every
day it hurts my feelings they hurts a
lot but you know what so far I haven't
been killed camp and I'm not planning
for that to happen anytime soon my mom
told me you can do 360 noscopes attempts
all day for the rest of your life but
you can't 360 noscope your way into a
good person and my person is stronger
than a thousand [ __ ] dripping
quickscopes
and yes I know there's no casting called
I'm not stupid and you know what I'll
take my pride over any cam cam and I'll
take my neck over any noscopes and I'll
take my montage over any sponsorship
said when may come my way and so what if
I like licking part they make great
music and so what if I record with the
webcam not everyone can afford it
hypercam 2.0 you think I care about Fame
and YouTube money you think we're also
better than me but you know what
I have 3000 subscribers now wait I have
3,000 subscribers now
I might be rich of duty money now with
my [ __ ] pants your got troller Lord
[ __ ] all of it for laugh he sad forget
to subscribe don't need you anyways back
oh Lord
ex ex ex ex ex ex ex ex ex